oh
we are live so no swearing
gym
um so hello good afternoon good morning
good evening wherever the hell you are
in the world and welcome to Sidetrack I
need to say Stargate then I don't know
why Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel we're with Matthew say hello
Matthew
and we're with Matthew's work friend Jim
hello
my dad calls me Jim so this is a bit
weird for me
um well anyway well I I realized not
long ago it took me too long to realize
this my boss is called James and Jim is
short for James I've never asked you
this is your name James
me yeah of course there you go
yeah so Jim's James I do ever get
but what's um what is your name James
because I get I get because my name's
Jamie so I get but is your name James
like no James
no but what's on your birth certificate
gaming
what's wrong with you people I get it
all the time is that j-a-i-m-e or
j-m-j-a-m-i-e it's the correct spelling
that's what it is
Spectators with us as well so my real my
real life surname gets mispronounced all
the time Jim will know my role actually
you know my real life certainly as well
but I'm not going to say it on here but
I get it
literally if needed me so
anyway you have my address I mean
um so we are here to talk about it was
only a bit of a chat because Jim is new
and I've already discovered that Jim is
a massive sci-fi geek much better than
Matthew Jesus
get me on the channel for my sci-fi
knowledge let's be honest
um
I get occasionally I'll get Jammy Jammy
Jammy I don't really shouldn't be saying
this I'm just going to get this all in
the comments now all right
self-inflicted injury yeah but Stargate
people so
um Matt you you've had a couple of
things you've thought you know we've
been bringing a fan somebody that hasn't
shared their opinion on Stargate before
so
do it what were you thinking
yeah well I mean I just wanted to ask
some questions just get a conversation
going about Stargate in general it
doesn't obviously we can go off from
tangents that's fine as long as as long
as it's relevant
don't talk about butt plugs that's one
rule
okay
if you watch any of our Lives watch any
of our Lives just skip to the end
especially if
um stormy's in it uh you you'll know
what I mean anyway
a few questions Stargate related
and hopefully just get a conversation
going
let's do it
so
we know stargate's coming back that's
what we talk about here on this channel
if you could revive any of the three
Stargate shows
what which one would it be and why
to me go on Jim you can go first sir
Universe
well obviously
um I mean that went badly I mean he's a
lovely guy but what the [__]
I just want to see how he fixes it not
in a comic not in a book I want to see
how they do it on film
I've got to see that and I've got to
rescue him
see I I also want the Stargate renewal
let's target Universe renewal Jake
for some reason he's got this thing the
first season was boring and it was
getting better but he still doesn't want
it to come back and I'm like why well I
just don't want it to you know I like um
I can't remember what we were discussing
but you're all right with like oh no
sorry like with them
the the Jason Momoa movie idea you said
that could come back but it's not
straight away
I don't mind Mr you
um conclusion I just don't want it to be
what we say because honestly it can't be
what we start with
no I don't think I don't think it could
be to Niche
yeah and and it's got to be something
they do a bit later and or as part of
another storyline they could do it as
like a double episode as part of a
season or something I'll be okay with
that
um we think they've already approached
um rush to come back so maybe that's the
plan
um Robert Carlisle we think they've tend
to leave myself maybe
um but out of the three
it's the one I least want to see
again
yeah
yeah I mean Atlantis I enjoyed it and
I've watched it several times
but it is my least favorite of the three
you've got to have a favorite you know
and at least I mean I'm going again
let me be that one it's only one
we did this uh we did this on the live
not long ago
um
what was our favorite Stargate
I think we all picked Atlantis so it's
interesting you said it's not your
favorite
[Music]
oh there's a Captain Caveman but happy
birthday
for me it was just sg1 but just like
it's perfected
um and but I still think
I think sg1 still my favorite if I'm
honest but I think it is Glory lines of
SG which is a little bit better
um but it was still left on a
cliffhanger
so I mean there's still a lot of story
to tell with Atlantis but again you
could bring Atlantis back without it
being
like the soul focus of the story like it
could bring SGU back and bring the
Destiny without it being there
focus of the story but what is it is it
is it just the Cliffhanger gym that you
want to come back or is it
yeah I mean that we knew what they were
doing they were they were just basically
Voyager and the Star Trek universe just
galavant and across with no real control
um and they fought battles and they
picked themselves up and then
then they went right we're going to make
our way through here and new old freeze
and I'll stay here valiantly and then
we'll fix it in the next series and then
well I know what you know this story was
picking up but
is it enough I'd like to see what
happened
I would like to see what the point of
the Destiny was
that would be interesting I don't think
they'll ever they'll ever answer that
question because it's one of those
questions that if you answer it then
what's next
yeah the ultimate question was
um there was a signal from the beginning
of the universe yeah uh essentially
hinting at God
yeah the creator of the entire universe
if you answer that question where do you
go from there
why does God need a Starship
yeah
God doesn't need a Starship we do to get
there you haven't seen the film yeah
the answer of everything because you
know it's 42. so um we've already had
the answer to everything and everything
always but um it would be nice if I I
would I would have loved an end bit of
just as a joke Brad Wright just doing
like um you know at the very end of the
very last episode you know like he he
he's done on the bridge thing he's
looking at the stars and he's a little
smile and then rush just goes just
writes on the inside of his thing 42 on
the inside
oh it just came up get game over like
he'd finish this game yeah and it never
happened
cryostasis but number 42 Crow so she's a
little nod to the uh that would be cool
that would have been cool
because yeah I had this thought of when
they re-reboot renew not reboot
um
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
reboot of either of any of the suit of
the shows it could just be Stargate
and that would Encompass all of it it
doesn't necessarily have to be this is a
reboot of universe this is a reboot of
Atlantis this is a reboot of sg1 it's
just this is a river of Stargate
I mean they all exist within the same
universe anyway and they did intertwine
us at certain points but
just just off the bat like that
I think it's a good idea
I think we'll get sort of the new that
we'll reference
the other things at times and what have
you been told is that it's an sg1
Revival but for what I understand that
is though it's just going to be sort of
like
because it's based on Earth it's going
through the gate
and the SGC is going to be there so it's
going I mean
it's sort of like a no-brainer really
and what they're basically saying is
we're going back to the original
format
um it's going to be on earth basically
so confession on Revival and it may be
it's an issue new su1 team
um because it would be by now because
everyone else moved on we saw them move
on we saw a you know
um teal could move on we'd seen that
Carter had already moved on obviously uh
RDA had retired and basically just Ben
Brown on his own I think by the end of
it
um so
Ben Brown is still young enough I think
looks alright enough that they could
bring him back and he could be
um still I wouldn't be a colonel he was
still a colonel when he but he's
actually a general by now surely but
he's still young enough that he could
still be there kick him ass if he wanted
to
um I like quite like Ben Broward
um
so yeah on the back of that
I have a question so
if they were to bring back any of the
old cast in whatever was obviously
having moved on
who would you have and what roles would
you put them in
go to Rodney back
somehow somehow get Rodney back because
he's he's who you oh well he's who I
watched for in Atlantis because
everything you you know he's going to
say you think yeah you're just so
self-centered but you're gonna fix it
well done yeah you know I like Rodney
Rodney is always my favorite character
in him yeah
um but I love Joe Flanagan so he could
come back for me all day
and um and he still looks like he could
still like do pull pull he could still
carry a show easy
um but the counter I'd want to see come
back
a fancy dual state so can she come back
she was only like a really minor part
but I mean if Rodney comes back you have
to because they got together together
um I didn't particularly like a
character I pretty much prefer Kaylee
um for Firefly but
really fancy
so
um yeah I think she's quite buff now
she's quite worked out yeah
um the character I actually wanted to
come back to is Sam Samantha General
cart General Samantha Carter that's the
way I want to be in there
um and I think that'd be a lovely way to
bring in maybe the odd little RDA come
come here I think would be good as well
yeah
um yeah because their balance we've got
together
retired general not bound by US military
law anymore
well you could do the bad right joke but
apparently that's one of the lines from
the Brad right script wizard is going to
come in in like you left your toothbrush
almost hinting that they just maybe
split up
um so but yeah General
that's all right how about you Matt what
would you bring back then
have you thought about answers for these
questions yeah of course no I think if I
started all the time
um I don't know my favorite character's
always been tilk hasn't it so
I don't know I just want I want to help
indeed in some way obviously he's now
going to be like the president of the
fridge of our nation or something like
that but
he's going to take a presidential system
not parliamentary
[Laughter]
over the course of like three seasons
it makes you like great again you know
the political system of the new Japanese
residential
um
I liked here I kind of love Christopher
George but um
it wouldn't even be my top 10 I don't
think
um see when I think of it
so as when I when I when I wasn't as
hardcore fan as I am now I've started
when I was thinking through the channels
and I saw it he's the one character that
I always recognized as being from
Stargate so for me he is Stargate it's
kind of like uh we're Star Trek if you
see data you know he's from Star yeah
yeah
or you see
um oh what's I don't know his name
anymore I can't think of it the robot
guy basically data again but from the
Orville you think okay
you know what I mean uh
so for me now as well yeah me too
I was literally thinking about him
earlier because I'm like I can
definitely see a lot of uh a lot of
inspiration from uh from Star Trek in
the Orville now I'm watching Star Trek
it is yeah
Isaac
yeah I mean I mean like not better but
um
yeah I mean Star Trek is I'm sorry the
Orville is basically a TV show because
they wouldn't make him make a Star Trek
F series and he really really wanted to
um
sorry and he has a crew member on
Enterprise as well if you watch it Matt
yeah
not not Isaac but
surf McFarlane yeah he's he works in the
engineering
he does he only sees like little but
[Music]
um
yeah
cool
I mean I'm a long way off on that yeah
you've got yeah you've got a little bit
of Star Trek to come through before you
get that bit but yeah it's still good
it's still good
what's next on that
so I think you've already answered this
but I want I want I want your honest
opinion of Stargate Universe because we
know
Jay's already said his piece about it so
we'll ignore him
but what is your honest opinion do you
think it deserves the hate that it gets
oh no
because you think it deserves the hate
that it gets
um and we already know you want to bring
it back but
I'm just talking a little bit about it
no I don't think it deserves hey at all
I mean it was
a valid part of the Stargate Universe
um the production values were incredible
um I mean it looks you look at someone
it's it's because I think it was a more
modern show and it was filmed much later
they've been able to invest better
Technologies into the making of it and
to me it looked incredible you know when
you saw the shuttles when you saw the
suits
um when you saw the discovery itself all
the visual effects they were so much
better but again I take it yeah because
time had Advanced and techniques had
Advanced but I enjoyed the stories and
it wasn't all goody goody Star Trek and
everybody's happy and jolly and there's
no bickering because bloody hell how
many pawn shops where they're at
universe
you know
um and it was more realistic I mean I'm
ex-air Force so I've seen that kind of
engagements with with other other people
in the military can't do it anymore in
their current job but
Jim actually used to work for Cheyenne
Mountain Complex he was an Airman and he
almost died three times
electrocuting info across the change
things like that yeah
come on
no
um
they did a reasonable job of showing
you know people getting getting on at
each other which which to my made it
more realistic if you can take into
effect the fact they were in a Starship
heading across the Galaxy you know as
realistic but uh I I think it was the
most realistic of the three shows but
a lot of people didn't like the the
nitpicking between people and I get that
I get because a lot of people want to
watch television and forget reality and
that would have brought things back to
normal and I get it you know I liked it
so that's yeah I've seen they've seen a
lot of shows since that follow
a more realistic approach with sci-fi
and I've always been had the stance that
Stargate Universe was just ahead of its
time at that point
the audience wasn't ready for it because
on the back of Stargate Atlantis being
canceled
and they wanted Stargate Atlantis
yes you wanted to have been off the air
for about a year but by that point
when Stargate Universe came along
was it three years
uh season three over Atlantis then we've
got two more years of Atlantis and then
we got so two years yeah three years
yeah well we had we had the basically
the finale which if you can call it that
of Stargate Atlantis that ended up
getting canceled in favor of Stargate
Universe which was a wildly different to
Stargate Atlantis obviously because it
was much darker much grittier in tone
it wasn't the bad wasn't a bad show at
all
um but I think it was just I I honestly
just think it was ahead of its time
with when it came out it come out five
years later after a Hiatus I think he
would have done a little bit better
um
going on a streaming platform somewhere
I think it would have done if you look
at a lot of stuff Apple they're doing
now it feels
a bit like SGU in the that it's yeah
gritty a bit more dark
um but I would say this it wasn't
necessarily ahead of its climate because
it was two years behind Battlestar
Galactica and in lots of ways it was a
lot like Battlestar Galactica
in tone in in design
um in style it it was they they
obviously looked about sunglasses
getting loads of critical Acclaim at the
time and the executives went do
something like that
because that looks great and and we want
some awards we want Awards awards would
be great and um
and and actually so I don't so I don't
necessarily agree it was ahead of its
time in that respect
um because BSG did well but I think I I
definitely think Catherine and the
attempt to then do
um the Stargate command that was ahead
of its time that was about three years
too soon because they tried to do it
online and that never really took off
but if they'd been about two or three
years later and got it on something like
Netflix
um that could have been good because the
main problem with the origins wasn't
really the idea it was that they had no
money at all I mean they were like
sellotape and stuff together and things
to try and make the show just just to
get the show out
um they had a pretty good cast the
writing wasn't very good and the budget
was just irrelevant
so that would that was definitely two or
not much before it's time either two or
three years and just just that and they
could have got it on
um so like Netflix and it would have
been awesome
um for me the main problem with SGU was
yeah it was compared to SGA and they
they really did try to do something very
different
um and I think they went too far
too far and trying to do something that
was real but I mean
like you said Jim the
the the way it was made was beautiful
The Way It Was Written was beautiful I
think they took too long
basically they took too much of the joy
out of it
and that yeah it was harsh yeah that was
the biggest problem they tried to have
Eli as the comic relief and it didn't
work he wasn't funny and then they kind
of even forgot to do that yeah often
through the by the start of the second
season they forgot
and then about halfway through the
season they started making he started
making film references again
and they were like oh shoot we forgot to
do that that's one of your things isn't
it yeah yeah
blue had an interview recently and he
basically said said that exact thing
that they they stopped right in those
parts of Eli and he said to one of them
I used to make all these references can
I can I carry on doing that and then
they said yeah and then he did
um
um but I mean that was one of the
funniest bits in the third episode is
when he was making a You Mad Men you
destroyed it and it was only really but
even that I'm just like
he just wasn't
maybe it just was a Stargate humor we
were used to sort of like sarcastic
we're used to
when we were used to Jack O'Neill and
John Shepard being witty and just taking
the piss out the villains yeah we didn't
really have that in the universe and
Rodney sarcasm I would I would think but
they did they couldn't write it I think
for David that was that was a problem
well I think he's a very different sort
of actor because he was the butt of a
lot of the jokes wasn't he and yeah he's
like that in real life so the writers
got to know him and they wrote Rodney in
lots of ways like him
recently about how David Hewlett and
Jason Momoa had towards the end of the
thing had a stand-up scream in each
other argument and then probably said
David Hewlett was doing my hair halfway
through the argument he was realized
Jason Momo is a lot bigger than me
years afterwards and it was only when
when David Hewlett got on sea he hadn't
actually spoken to Jason Momoa in ages
so when he got the call of his agent he
was like they had this character and
apparently my mother just sort of went
Hewlett something you could be perfect
for it sort of thing and so he looked at
the phone call and he's not like you
sure this isn't just a trick to beat me
up
their friendship enough you know
um and their finer games but I think um
Joe Flanagan actually to do a little bit
of matchmaking sort of thing to
sort them out but um imagine pissing off
Jason Momoa you wouldn't wonder would
you no
she said about my wife's favorite
character from the show
I think she's many of these many wives
um
Oliver's getting up there yes thank you
it was
um I said oh origin should have been a
movie I I agree with that if you watch
it all as one because I think they did
like a super cut and it's just called
Stargate Catherine or something yeah um
that it is a lot better if you're
watching like that yeah 100 definitely
um I would argue as well that's that's
what it would have been perfect to
stream for a stream of service because
that would have been a perfect like
Netflix movie
or um you know and that would have been
that's what the sort of thing they'd
have done as well that's the sort of
thing they were doing back then
you know like eight eight years ago
eight nine years ago
um like I said if it was three years
later when Netflix was in their Prime of
just chucking money at everything if
they had a decent budget they'd have had
a much better story yeah 2017 2018
instead of when was it 2014 2015 26
something like that wasn't it 2015 I
think yeah I think it's something like
that wasn't it so as United just been
scored against
no excellent
um so yeah
2018 it come out
it came in 2018 so I think that's I
think well I think they maybe they made
the mistake they know it wasn't too
early because I think that's Prime
Netflix time
they made the mistake of trying to make
it an internet thing and they what they
should have done was trying to sell it
against Netflix which is maybe what
we're talking about ahead of its time in
that that's what they do now
is that's what a lot of these that's
what a lot of studios are doing now is
they're producing stuff for other people
like Disney are doing it and then
they're trying to sell them to other
channels and things rather than put it
on just their streaming services so I
think that would have been HBO that's
their thing they're like Netflix what do
you want we'll make it anything which
one
um and uh so that's maybe more aware of
the way I'm thinking that they should
just I'll try to sell it something like
Netflix and make some money it would be
so much better
but they didn't and we missed some
opportunities because that and then
could have been the Catalyst to kick off
because then Brad was approached
just after that to write this first
script so it was 2019 he wrote the
script for the for the reboot the
Revival
um if Catherine had had a bit more money
spent on it and maybe like I said got on
Netflix or something because Stargate
was on Netflix at that point wasn't I
think it would definitely okay
I think it was over here so Netflix
probably would have eaten it up so that
was the mistake
which is a shame we missed a massive
opportunity there and friend of the
channel channel Jenny Steven was
actually involved in that and
um ah yeah if we can get her on I've got
questions for stuck Origins for her
more more around
um what was the recept what was the
reaction in the office to to what the
fans thought of it that's what I want to
ask her
as a football thing just happened Jay
a little bit
damn that kickball
give us a very famous video if you're a
side tracker if um when United lost to
Liverpool seven nil
and um I was live
oh yeah oh no and you're just seeing me
crying
I'm not surprised I'm not surprised
though I would I would have as well
who are they playing there yeah
yeah
um David just had a a good point Netflix
if Netflix had started it would have had
three seasons and they got canceled that
happened to Travelers so
um
yeah but I don't think it would have
been I think the point would have been
it would have been a a special thing so
it would have got the three seasons
because then the main show would have
gone on MGM so what what
um
they were doing what what Brad Wright
was doing would have actually gone to
Amazon Prime actually
um but Amazon Prime would have been
perfect for this actually a screw
Netflix Amazon Prime should have done
Catherine that was really about right
for them as well and then gone into the
new um because that's that's what that's
who the customer was it was Amazon Prime
it was always going to have the new
Stargate series and Amazon Prime have
actually shown that when they commit to
something even if everyone hates it they
really commit rings of power we're
getting five seasons of that regardless
of if if no one watches it we'll still
get five seasons of that crap
um they commit
so I'm gonna call you
there's some good things like the boys
so we can forgive them a little bit yeah
I've never watched it
don't watch it with your wife the love
of God I made that mistake
I want to show you my misses
[Music]
but I don't know that first episode or
even that second episode
you won't know this gym but in the
second episode something happens
and it made me fall in love with this
show essentially just think of a bomb
and someone's ass
it was funny
um
I piqued your curiosity enough for you
to watch no it's like indestructible
isn't it so they need to kill them
um I think we need a spin-off show with
Daniel Jackson and Carson and just and
they call it like um it's like The Odd
Couple and it's just And the tagline is
is you can't kill us it doesn't matter
what you do we won't die and it's just
like it's like a zombie Walking Dead
series or something right just enough
sounds good
that would be good
I've got some other general questions
but none of them are as exciting as what
I've already asked I'm saving the boring
monster last
I'm hoping we can we can just you know
get through and just just find things to
talk about
I already started I or guys get into the
comments and ask us a question if you'd
like
as well secular monk says just as long
as Val is nowhere in the show I loved
Walla what what did you like about it
yeah
and she was funny
I love it my voice is gone I really like
that
was amazing I thought it was brilliant a
relationship between her the
relationship between Lana and Daniel
Jackson is great I loved it
it's really fun and the way she's like I
always listen to call um teal muscles
and things like that and their
relationship was funny and she was she I
know I loved it but I think some people
really hated
[Music]
um
just overused maybe but um this because
you're such a series the main sort of
like energy character in the last couple
of Seasons so but maybe yeah I can kind
of see that but um
I love the dynamic of her character
um like the backstory of her character
being the katesh be having like her
insights for the gold especially
um
she said she said something quite quite
good uh at the uh extraction of bar
it's like uh witnessing an extraction is
one thing but
experiencing it is another like that
kind of thing I always loved about her
yeah please continue the great contents
and conversations judican we will just
to use the well done and thank you so
much for the contribution it really
helps
you could have had a spinner with a dad
couldn't we
[Laughter]
um I think a lot of people's hated those
last couple of seasons some people
really I thought they were really good
they are my least favorite of of sg1 but
I still watch them you know nothing
would stop me watching it
I think I liked it just as much because
I just think it just reinvented itself a
little bit I quite like the all right
like to the extreme well we've had the
Ancients the benevolent ancients that
well they're not really benevolent there
the life forms of the Ancients that
could do anything to help us if they
wanted to but they don't because of
their rules let's make an evil version
of them that will do stuff but they'll
do it evenly I thought that was
brilliant yeah Sarah makes a good point
about father though maybe she's a bit
too much of a cartoon
um
I think they improved her character as
it went on she did develop
I I almost wish we'd seen
the relationship with Daniel sort of
kick on a bit it was almost like they
thought they were going to get another
season or something and I know we got
the special where they were you know on
the um on the ship for years and and
their relationship
um it developed back but I wish we'd
seen that a bit more but maybe it was
going to win the movie
um I don't know but um
I would have loved to have seen the
difference because in the in the in the
last episode you saw her and Daniel well
you saw you saw her vulnerable which is
something you've never you you have seen
a vulnerable before but she lets herself
be vulnerable in this scene with Daniel
where she basically cries
um
and then they they fall in love they get
together and they were there together
for like 50 years or whatever I because
time then reset I'd like to have seen
what happened had they not been in that
situation
whether it was Stockholm syndrome kind
of think of the stuck in stuck in space
stuck in a ship and that's why it
happened or if it was just Destiny and
they were gonna it was gonna happen
anyway
maybe we'll find out in the news really
because maybe called you black will be
any I don't know she could be maybe yeah
because everything else sci-fi at the
moment so hey Andrew
yeah
so much makeup you can't help with it
all right well that's an interesting
question then
Valor has had a couple of votes now for
the most irritating character every
series has a character you just go if I
met him I'd punch him in the face or her
it could be her
um who is the most irritating character
across the three seasons and I'm going
to throw a little bit of a curveball
straight away and I'm gonna vote for Eli
like obviously
is that the guy with a ponytail yes
it was it was written like a cartoon
villain though really weren't they it
was so duplicitous and oh sir
he's done this you know and yeah that'd
kick him out a lot yeah
Atlantis where Caldwell basically had to
go holding him
they dressed that entire episode up to
make us think it was him and I think
that's why we all hate him because he's
a smarmy get as well but yeah we were
supposed to hate him he's supposed to be
because what he's supposed to do you're
supposed to hate him even more than we
hate Rodney I think and everybody hated
Rodney at times he was just he was a
lovely episode with the Catalyst about
hatred yeah
um
I think I throw in Eli though because I
really don't like David blue
so I might be transferring there we're
never getting him on the channel put it
this way if he ever comes over town
right you're gonna have to deal with him
because I can't deal with him
um I mean I did try and and because he
followed he followed me on Tick Tock for
like literally three seconds
he followed me and I I was like I'll
leave you a message you didn't I went up
David Blues followed followed it like
I'm like amazing I went to message him
and it's like this person doesn't follow
you I'm like
so he's obviously seen the videos he's
accidentally hit follow and then just
unfollowed
so what's your thoughts on the last
episode of SG of season 10 ST1 and I
think it was brilliant rather than the
fact that Daniel and Vala hooking up
and thank you again for the the Super
Chat so what do we think
I I I have two minds about the final
episode I did like it
but I think Arc of Truth is the last
episode
yeah movie but it's the last episode
um
yeah is is the conclusion to sg1 so
but I like done ending it was a it was a
good episode
um ultimately it didn't
have any bearing on anything other than
the fact that teal is now 50 years older
yeah he's got a white yeah
realistically it's the most useless
episode there is because it did nothing
apart from age tilk
but I liked it I thought it was really
good Richard Dean Anderson wasn't in
Italy
no no I think so it wasn't that was
always
wrong for me I know who's then in
Continuum which is which was always the
plan really but how do you have an ST1
finale
they did think they were going to get
season 11 didn't they so it wasn't it
wasn't actually meant to be
um a finale
[Music]
yeah there were plans for season 11 so
uh I think that show would still be
going
it moves up to the creators I just could
go
it's one of those shows like er and
stuff like that you can just re you just
keep reform because the the basic
story is the basic principle of the plot
something is quite adaptable you can
just change the team over there it's
infinite isn't it it's infinite they can
just go through the gate somewhere there
how we need to start get mayborne
Laura Smith said rayak
as a new I I I I hated rayak
that's the sun wasn't it so yeah yeah
um
that's a bit harsh
um yeah he was an idiot
Stargate was the first movie
for being technical
um but yes it was it was every release
it was released on DVDs is a movie the
boobs version got a like like a movie
version
and then as soon as they took as soon as
they sort of produced has got any sort
of power at all they immediately removed
the boobs thing they were forced to put
in by the um by the by MGM basically
um
but yeah
it was like um Star Trek it was like um
wharf's kid
responsible
keep an eye on him and then next time
you see him you think he looks a bit
different
all of a sudden it says there's like
he's gone on holiday and come back a
different person yeah that's strange
like that in EastEnders what's that
guy's name Ben it was it was a little
nerdy kid then he went to jail and
became another kid and then he's grown
up again he's another he's another
accent there's been three bends at this
point
right but
my mom does so every time I go down to
Essex where I'm from she puts it on and
I'm like who's that she goes that's Ben
that's not Ben what about this guy oh no
he's changed
who's been the same actor for like 50
[__] years
babies it wasn't as well thank you they
don't even pretend they're just a new
actor was turned up again
yeah um okay who is the most annoying
sort of one-off
villain
Lucius
no he was funny he was funny it was
funny but you wouldn't want him around
all the time
I I know I love the episode I'm trying
but I didn't like the character
Harlan was it hard yeah
um what's the um
no the guy that made the robots
oh Harlem might have been the guy that
made the robots actually the robots yeah
um
I can't think of his name
um I'm going to Google it come try it I
just thought it was a it was slightly
annoying episode it was hard his name
was Harlan yeah
I agreed with you immediately
and why you even questioning that
yeah
I'm trying to I'm trying to play yeah
thank you
yes
Harlan made the robots Harlan Ergo made
the the thing in their heads wasn't it
the thing in their heads yeah that one
yeah because he projected himself into
the brain they couldn't get rid of him
um but Tom delawaree Tom de Luis Dom
DeLuise is just a brilliant actor and I
adore him in um and Cannonball Run
so
for me the the worst character
was that that Gould guy who just wanted
to eat and eat and eat give me food give
me food
I'm like get off yeah
what was his name his name was
ah
I know what you mean because it's the
episode where they go hang on your voice
isn't deep anymore yeah we don't have to
we don't have to talk like that yeah
[Laughter]
there you go especially having his dad
yeah
um cupcakes
um
that might have been the gold
near us
yeah
um
there's quite a few an issue one
actually isn't it I don't think it's
really an SGA
SGU I can't remember any villains were
um they had the uh actual aliens with no
personality but we never and they just
bought themselves didn't they yeah
oh Evolution Alliance I guess yeah
another chick that played um uh
big boobed woman Tomb Raider woman
yeah I know who you mean she played the
big boob two major woman anyway for
years
um I've just gotta I'm gonna be back in
one sec talking myself
okay
yeah I mean the ocean Alliance they had
the guy that was in Prison Break
they had daddy's head cut off in prison
and he was horrible he must be such a
good actor
I've just I've just watched him I've
just watched the episode
um
oh what happened so
I can't remember the girl's name she
gets a box delivered to the ship and
basically saying you and now you have to
be married to this person the person
that comes on the ship is his name was
uh Sonic Miller
is that guy
really
yeah Deanna yeah Deanna Troy
um
Robert never that's his name
I saw his face obviously he's very very
young version of it and I'm like who is
that he looks very familiar so I Googled
it and it was it was him but he was also
in Heroes and he was amazing in Heroes
I'd say it must be a good actor because
it's always awesome
hello hello
uh yeah in prison break with the uh
pocket yeah yeah
it it is playing vile characters and uh
it does it really well so I guess in
real life he must be a nice guy
uh
so yeah I think there's quite a few
irritating characters as Target of these
actually
you can actually argue though the um the
spider's replicators were a stupid
villain and I actually thought they were
some of the best episodes but really or
you just it just every every episode it
was just like loads of spiders
and then a door had shot near a screen
from the other side I want to see how a
replicator kills people
yeah
yeah come over here
in the moot Which movie was it was it
Arc of Truth yeah I think it was
where they took over the person they
literally became Terminator
that was good that was like this this is
what I'd imagine they do to a person but
we never got to see it and that's that's
essentially it
yeah that was quite good I like that
actor as well he's a big fellow Indian
yeah the um yeah went into the back of
his neck and that was pretty good
um and then
he was walking
um hello Harris yeah
yeah he's taking the first season he
said we need a catheter I didn't go for
a wee
um
I've got hand sanitizer sometimes hand
sanitized oh
so I use that instead
it's in there
yeah but that was the replicators one of
[Laughter]
I could actually get one from work two
more questions they're the most boring
ones but it might spawn something
interesting yeah you never know so the
first one is do you remember the first
episode you ever watched no
next question yes I
watched it when it came out
actually I wasn't oh yeah you watched it
from the beginning yeah
I start in season four
well because I'm old enough to have
actually gone to the cinema to watch
Stargate 94.
um yeah I was two old men yeah
because I'm that old
um but
I loved the I loved the original movie
so when they I heard there's a Stargate
series coming out I was like yippee and
then I heard that Richard Dean Anderson
MacGyver was going to be in it and I was
like
so I watched you know I watched children
I watched it from the start
I think I was posted overseas when it
came on TV so I never got to see it and
then I just not even considered watching
it for for whatever reason I don't know
I love the movie and then uh my wife and
I got together and she'd been a big fan
of it since it launched and said look
watch it it's on sky and I watched it
and I went I've been missing something
really good here and I was hooked I
can't tell you what episode it was I
don't remember
there was probably Gould in it you know
is there an episode that stands out for
you though
that you go this is now my favorite show
this this has gone to another level this
is brilliant yeah yeah the the one with
the time loops
uh yeah okay yeah
right simply because of in the middle of
my backswing yeah you know
um
been a member for a month thank you sir
best episodes yeah season three SGA was
good
um
I want to share to my son that I'm live
because he's playing music can you hear
the music was it right
now
just bothering me
um for me
yeah
um for me it was the double episode and
then the episode when the replicators
aboard the Russian sub
that was when I went this show is
special this does this is this isn't
just a good show this is a great show so
yeah yeah
Matt can you remember the first episode
you watched them as you are I can't
remember the specific but it was around
season four
and I remember watching it so I'll
I had
the person my mum was with at the time
was a massive Stargate fan
multiples multiple times
that's right yeah he was a massive
you tried to get mentioned multiple
times and I
I don't know you're not my dad
he got me into Doctor Who to be fair so
when when the Revival come out
um me and him watched it together and
then I became a massive fan of Doctor
Who but I I didn't sit down and watch
Stargate for a really long time and then
he was watching it I caught an episode
around season four
and I I I fell in love with it at that
point even though he told me that all
this time like you need to watch this
this is great so
because it was on Skype but I can't
remember how I ended up watching season
one
because it was like reruns at that point
it wasn't three months was it
they didn't do reruns I don't know how I
managed to watch season one two three
and one two and three but I did so I
probably downloaded it Tarrant to do or
something I was gonna say BitTorrent
yeah it's probably something like that
and uh yeah just fell in love with it
you look very sort of person that would
know how bitter Talent worked I never
knew how Bitcoin worked
of course I know how it works I use it
on the
on the never because I'm a good boy
we get our Linux distros isn't it yes
okay yeah
did they ever do an episode of Stargate
and any of the seasons that you remember
sort of go in
um
I'm never watching that again sort of
thing but you know I'd like to because
there's a few Star Trek episodes over
the years that I've gone that is just
bad
so that I will I refuse to watch the if
it came on you'd immediately turn it off
uh yeah the episode with the the people
covered in white chalk that episode is
completely boring I hate it
it's really boring it's like a disease
or something because their immune
system's crap and they get disease and
the flowers are something coming up
white balls yeah yeah yeah and and then
they cure it and then we never see them
again
Crystal School episodes yeah I wasn't a
big fan of that do you remember the
episode when um they brought a device
back and it's it's shot spikes out and
it just went through Neil's shoulder and
pinned to me as well yeah I thought that
was a boring episodes
[Music]
remove me
I just remember
I have an episode that angered me that I
didn't want to watch it again but not
because it was bad because of what they
did
and they killed Janet
okay no
just horrified
horrified she came back she exists in in
the parallel universe yeah made me cry I
thought this I thought that was just
what we needed at that time
didn't see it coming but yeah that's the
idea of it yeah I didn't like the one
with the retoo
the invisible thing with the little bold
kid I was sort of expecting that to come
back and they sort of mentioned the
retoo a couple of times but yeah there's
a lot of there's a lot of alien races
and Stargate that we never got to see
Rita is one of them the giant aliens
from Crystal Skull
those why why
babies with no music system that I
mentioned
so then where everyone loves her episode
I watched that video about that episode
a couple of weeks ago it is it's not a
very good episode but um the acting's
good though it's like from a like a
I respect the episode because it was it
was really well after David Hewlett
particularly good in it but um it was a
slightly boring episode is that the
episode where David uh sorry Rodney's
filming himself yeah like little German
oh yeah yeah I like that one I thought
that was all right
yeah he's well acted I just thought it
was a good one there's a couple there's
always episodes though that are a bit
I can't get through this because they're
doing 22 Episodes
they're not all going to be gold they're
not a Star Trek they're not
in anything else either to be honest so
I always found the Filler episodes
boring the um the catch up the clip
shows
I mean
more than other clip shows like that's
you have a story that makes it kind of
make sense but they're still boring
because I've already seen what what
they're showing so lots of other shows
will just have the characters sat around
going do you remember that time I don't
need to show the clip and that's what
God's painful and
but at least they get they did try to
make a thing out of it and Star Trek did
a couple of Filler episodes where they
gave they stopped doing them but um they
did a couple early on and yeah they're
not very good but um Stargate kept with
it they did a couple of episodes every
season and then on the clips of a
flashback video every season but the
natural soldiers at the start walking up
to the the entrance hope when with his
hand on the rifle it's like come on film
some new stuff come on
that the best filler episode
which it is a filler episode but you
could argue it's not is it is this 200
episode
I love that I loved it I love the
puppets going through the Starkey and
the strings being cut
she's never gonna talk to her again
I thought it was great he disagrees with
me on pretty much everything so it's
fine
I I do love the 200th episode
for what it was because it was a
celebration yeah of
um the show I wouldn't watch it again
I might watch it next I haven't watched
it in years actually so I might have to
get it out and watch it again just
because I have I literally haven't
watched it I think probably since it
came out since it was aired
[Music]
um
because it is a bit stupid oh it's
completely
completely stupid well I I argued this
recently because Star Trek the strangely
worlds is just in a musical episode I
refuse to watch it I wish I had
um
and I I my argument there was
this isn't the 200th episode this is
this is the 19th episode of strange new
worlds
how dare you do an episode that is just
like
for yourselves basically yeah
so the flash did the flash did something
similar a musical episode it was awful
simply because Grant Gustin
was in Glee which is a musical Thing
and because he could sing so they're
like to sing on the flash yes he could
sing but it's so bad it's so cringy it
doesn't fit in that's that's why I
refuse to watch it I was like no I'll
just not watch it this week I'll wait
till next week
but I've also that sci-fi should that
the reason why a couple of reasons why I
don't like the the musical episode of
strangers as well is because it made no
logical sense
and they just started singing they all
there was no like if they'd have been
like a telepathy thing in the storyline
there's an alien telepathy transmitting
they all then they all know the words to
the songs but there wasn't it was just
it was like a reality thing they said
well it's just a reality
um someone that makes it make any sense
um
sci-fi should always make at least a
little bit of sense there should always
be like a nugget of like science in
there and then they build the fiction
around it you know
um and Star Trek did that loads and got
it wrong sometimes got the theory that
the science wrong but there's always
that nugget of like truth in the middle
and um
that I also Stargate was better than
Star Trek at that to be fair
um but that episode with the thing just
didn't make any sense
I actually Buffy did do a sort of a
musical Thing it fit better than Apple's
the best Buffy episode I want to learn
the one that nobody could speak the
whole episode is silent that was
brilliant terrifying villains and all
them once it used to float
that's saru out of Discovery he was the
lead one of them yeah
um so
um yeah yeah you're right he was the
main one you see at the time at the
front
oh yeah I forgot where I was going sorry
sorry it was but yeah well it's musical
bad
yeah yeah we can agree on that yeah no
one point is they did that completely as
a do what you want go crazy just do
something stupid you can do whatever you
want but they deserved it
they don't it was the 200th episode they
deserved a bit of silliness they
deserved something that was a bit
just ridiculous you know um and even
though it's not the best Stargate
episode ever made
um it's I I can tip my hat too because I
like oh yeah you deserve that guys
well done the the Farscape parody really
did make me laugh with
the fact that they didn't even play
their own characters
The Wizard of Oz reference you just you
can see if like a couple of seconds
Brown proud is just like
hmm
oh no that's Jackson actually
yeah
what was your last question then
last one is who is your favorite villain
of the entire franchise
ball
I just thought he was so good when he
was torture and Jack and dropping the
blades into him and stuff and I just
thought yeah this is this yeah he was so
cool with it and he became the villain
we wanted to hey and we we love to hate
sort of thing by the end
um
and the bit where he stood on the ramp
with the with the projection and uh just
like
and then eventually I'm sorry I was
enjoying a lovely brunch
and then um Sam's dad starts giving him
hints on how to fight the replicators
and he just said no no no
what's his name
Jacob
what is it Jacob so Jacob Jacob stop
stop stop
you're gonna lose and you're gonna die
and we will laugh
um I just thought that was just
brilliant I just love that
um so now ball was well was probably my
favorite as well
um
I can't tell you in terms of like
actually scary villains Anubis is the
one for me oh yeah anybody Without a
Face
yeah yeah yeah
I think he was one of the most dangerous
villains in all of sci-fi because I mean
he came like back close to wiping out
all life even bloody um thingy from
Marvel only
you know
Thanos and the ubis was going to wipe
out everything
the other limits
did it because he thought it was he
Thanos thought he was the good guy and
lubis knows he's the bad guy and he just
wants to be the bad guy
I'm going to be the best villain I can
be well he was so bad that the gold
tried to get rid of him
yeah it was Exile wasn't he so yeah yeah
they were like this guy's a bit of a
prick we gotta get rid of this guy he's
crazy if the goal will think you're
crazy you're freaking crazy
uh but yeah I would yeah Anubis was the
best
it was the most scary villain
what about character that only appeared
once
it was it was the character thing you
only appeared once that you wish had
returned
I know I know it to me and I know what
Harris will say immediately
yeah
he always talks about Irish Buck
he was incredible I I wanted to see how
to spot come back I would love to see
him in return
I just watched Ted again the other night
so that's
made me smile
um
yeah into Harris yeah
it feels so predictable sir
man shimmerman linear the destroyer of
worlds yeah that was a good one
he'd like the storyline to be honest it
was it was quite good and then having
her loser memories at the end was
it's clever yeah it was good
the um I know she appeared in a couple
of episodes but you know that the the
goals that released the stink that made
everybody do what she wanted I didn't
like that character yeah
she's I'm fine that she died
I was okay
I climbed up that flaming bathtub or
whatever yeah yeah I liked uh Seth
oh
you've got a punched him as well
because bile just sort of like sorry
Puffy's just sort of like took over
didn't he and we never saw him again
um Soca and he just took over so can't
sleep and we never we and we didn't see
it as well it happened off camera as
well he's supposed to be like this
terrifying villain goal kind of office
just sort of like off camera
just took over
um
didn't so car get defeated because
Anubis was coming into power it was an
Anubis I think so
because you see him with the lesions on
his face and that was was that's with
that's what happens when Anubis takes
over your body
there might be a different way I can't
remember
I think that was a different goal but um
yeah I don't I don't remember what
happened so kind of actually
too much too much Target to try to
remember
uh you know what this means it means you
have to watch it again
I am going to start watching it again
it's my next
it's my next show I'm going to watch
Travelers and then I'm going to watch
sg1 again
yes Travelers first thank you
after I've watched Star Trek Discovery
season four and I'm on more episodes in
and I fluffing hate it I hate it it's
awful so much it's awesome
but I was made to watch it by
um the mark from the solar the the
shuttle podcast and the shuttle pod show
they say no you gotta watch it go on go
and watch it you got to watch it so I
said okay I'll watch it and then there's
some butterflies the villain butterfly
dudes and I was like oh God I hate this
show so much
um and a planet's been destroyed and I
don't care
um uh yeah I think Apophis killed Ahsoka
anyway and um and now the end the
discovery has got floating the cells and
it's flying around holding everyone and
I often hate it it's awful
um but I've got to watch it because I've
said I will
well there's only one more season
thankfully
yeah then we get Star Trek 90210 instead
teenage is really nice maybe maybe
with Tilly that's what people said about
Stargate Universe it was Stargate 90210
everyone was like young what
everyone was younger
rush and Telford and yeah that's two
people that were older but you
absolutely you had
um
they're all younger than the the than
what we had originally
yeah it was it was young sexy people
that's what that's what that's anything
with young sexy people is 90210 that's
that's tends to be what people say I
like young and sexy people
United
martial is martial is warming up
good fantastic yeah
what's up anyway
so I've got no more questions so well I
I just want to ask one question of the
gym then before you your head I think so
there's the it looks like we're getting
a movie
is the rumor
um that won't go away
um do you have any strong feeling either
way I mean how would you like to see the
franchise rebooted if it if you have the
option I think if they make a movie
great and we watch it and then it gets
enough of an audience score for them to
go yeah let's Kickstart a series from
that bring back the series I mean I'd
just love to see more Stargate in
whatever form we can get it you know uh
the stories are good I definitely want
to see Richard Dean Anderson back in it
you know um because to me
like I said I didn't enjoy the last two
series as much as the previous eight
simply because no Jack O'Neill and to me
Jack O'Neill a Star Trek is a Stargate
like to me Captain Kirk was Star Trek
you know that was the show around the
character
um and and so if we could get Richard
Dean Anderson involved
fantastic you know I'll I'll watch it
whatever but yeah give me a series give
me a movie I'll keep going another
question for you in a second then
okay Captain Caveman thank you so much
for the Super Chat which character do
you hate that they killed off for me it
was the guy who ran uh the gate in SGA
who was the weapons platform with Rodney
that they got killed in the end
I'm trying to remember which character
that was it was the reason I I can't do
that was it the sergeant guy sergeant
and he and and uh when they when they
crashed the puddle jumper didn't he get
sort of caught underneath
um but okay so who who do they kill off
then I mean for you then it'll be
um the doctor
in here
they didn't kill off a lot of characters
there didn't they really
I didn't like that they killed off Janet
but I I was more devastated when they
killed off Carson in yeah yeah really
they killed him off for like a minute
it was in shock of it
it was a shock the way they did it was
good though I mean you're watching it
and I'm going it's gonna blow up
it's when you watch it again and then
you realize how much he's been isolated
from everybody else before they kill him
off and you just feel for the guy you
know the whole and that's a such a good
episode all the way through the episode
you're going someone's getting it in
this episode this episode's too good
someone's getting it and then at the end
you see they set it up they think it
could be anyway don't you then it's like
oh
they're gonna be
peeling their muscles
[Laughter]
clever episode
he should have been Scotty in the movies
instead of Simon Peg of course he should
yeah I'm doing a stark at Universe
health and safety Guy video I'm
hopefully going to record it tomorrow
I've sort of started planning it but um
the guy I'm gonna do it that he's really
nervous and they're like he's like [__]
what was that
it goes at least at the SGC every room
he didn't go through he wasn't trying to
kill you
tries to kill us
feel to failed again here we go
again and um so I make a big deal about
that so
foreign
but I think they should kill him
right but before you calm down calm down
Matthew I'm going to explain it I'm
going to explain it again I'm arguing
this with
um uh the chat from the other video the
other night and he really I mean we've
argued again and that's honestly the um
the message is is always just like mac
um I forgot his name for a second uh
Matt from um the um MacGyver podcast and
he's he really really hates this idea
but my thinking is
is is 80 is 78 years or 77 or 78 years
old he's not going to do much and if he
doesn't if he says look I'll come to the
movie but I'm not doing anything else
this character deserves to go out
in a bang in a close recording in an
amazing way I wanted to go out in a way
that you know we think about like for
years as a hero as well you know what's
quite you know as a bank their argument
was that way yeah but I want to see him
come back and do the odd little visit
and stuff like this so do you want the
character to go out in a whimper you
know I mean or do you want the character
to go out
in a way you remember and I'm like I
want to go I want him to go out in a way
I remember
um and if he does the other little Cameo
here and there he could do little
I'm sorry she could bring him back from
like little
remembering all your flashbacks are
going to be really wanted to but I
wanted to go in a way you remember
see my problem with it
my problem with with killing off Jack
because you want it to be in so they do
a movie first you want him to kill him
in the movie that to me if you kill off
Jack one of the most vital characters of
Stargate in the first thing you're doing
when you bring back Stargate is it's
just like Hey we're bringing back
Stargate now who is your favorite
character we're gonna kill him
that doesn't sit right with me he's
already gone and don't you think that's
a nice way to sort of go that's the end
of Stargate and this is new
it's a Divine you know there's a way to
kick off into the new series hand over
to a new you first officer
they they they they they could do a
Handover without killing him yeah but
they could have had a little with him if
you don't want I'm just sitting by a
lake with no fishing again do you come
on you you could argue they already did
the Handover back when um Ben bradder
took over so you don't need to kill him
it's already done
so then we don't need to see him at all
don't you don't you want to see him
I don't need to
oh
you would rather not have him at all
correct because I want him to live yeah
that man raised me Uncle Jack O'Neill
and I'm not talking about killing
Richard Dean Anderson literally I don't
I mean I mean I know he he does a lot
for his art but I don't mean like
literally blow him up
I
like the hope that these characters can
come back at some point and I just don't
want him to die bring Jack back as young
Jack growing up because he's had got
Jack's memories up till then
and then you've still got Jack O'Neill
[Laughter]
yes technically but no
great say from Johnstone
um
so this is a bit like when they've just
done
um
uh Star Trek card and Picard can't run
or walk it can barely move the man's 103
years old right and the show is spaced
around him and he's supposed to be the
hero he is
frail
let's say the least I'm pretty sure if I
crunched Captain Picard in the face he'd
die instantly
and I and I can't punch very hard he's
an old man
I'm very old man but it's a bit
embarrassing because you got this great
heroic character and it's a bit like
um
can he stand that long or is he gonna
need to go for a week
um
is this nurse going to be in this
episode
but do you really want that for Richard
Dean Anderson
him coming back and being like 85 years
old and no I don't I just I just don't
want his character to die
and also I don't want a deep fake
version of them in the future I don't
want that
well the main thing is that none of
these people can ever be recast we never
we can never have another O'Neill ever
and that's the main thing I would love
to see a massive my favorite character
I would love to see him slap bang in the
middle of the movie and I would love to
see him go out on a massive bank and I
think it would be amazing
um
and that if if that if that's what the
actor wanted to do and he fancy doing it
and and he said well look I'm this is
this is a last hurray for me
um I would love it go out of here I
think it'd be awesome and and like I
said you can have him ascend
it's not gonna make me make or break
where I'm gonna watch Stargate or not if
he dies or if he's in it if he's not I
would just I just have my preferences
and I'm gonna watch it either way but I
just don't want him to die when we walk
out of the cinema and he's and he's dead
I'm there crying
as long as you don't blame me
I I probably will yeah I've said it
first
I swear to God I do get again
occasionally do get blamed for these
things whenever I do a video and I get
some stuff to lose out I'll we will get
comments going
we hate you into
and like down thumbs on the videos and
I'm like it's it's not my fault
I didn't do it
if
she's going out again
there are people out there that are sort
of like transference blame me that Brad
Wright wasn't involved because that's
the first one
yeah you've influenced them you've
influenced him
a bit a bit like a Homer Simpson and
Jack with the stones
maybe I don't know but um I was gonna
say I'm going to direct line to Amazon
but I do know
so
I might be over exaggerating that direct
line a little bit but
Jeffrey's number
yeah I've got one person's number anyway
I want a lovely chat and Jim love
absolutely lovely to meet you sir thank
you I hope we will see you again because
you actually know Star Trek and I can
talk with you and Matt will know soon
so in in about five years we'll be able
to include Matthew in Wisconsin yeah
wait till it gets better way to your
Deep Space Nine yeah
the best that's it my two favorite
episodes of Star Trek ever were the two
Mirror Universe episodes at the end of
Enterprise through Mira dartley
yeah I always love the mirror episodes
those two in particularly yeah Deep
Space Nine when they went back to the
the um troubled uh tribulations
from the original series isn't it with
the goatees and
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
in trails and tribulations though did
you notice David Gerald is actually a
cast member walking up and down the
Corolla yeah yeah it's really good
um the episode when they went back in
time and did the um
um oh no it was Voyager wasn't it
Voyager did the
um uh at the observatory
episode The Country episode because he
actually is on the bridge yeah they got
Gulu back and everything yeah fantastic
fantastic you've got so much to learn
Matt yeah back in Ledger the Blu-rays
mate don't you worry and then once you
watch them in the pale moonlight
really
cool storylines again you've got to wait
firm Cisco to go bald as soon as Cisco
goes ball
it's amazing it's really really good and
that was basically I am the actor ah
Avery Brooks was in um a series
um a cop show series basically Hulk or
something on it
Spencer for Hire
um so he did this but they were doing a
TV movie but he actually had to go bald
and do the goatee because that's what
the hawk character did so he had to do
it
um and they just and everybody just went
yeah so we kept it
but um that's when it got good when the
device comes in
and also Matt you like the Orville the
doctor from the Orville is uh Ben
Cisco's girlfriend
ah yeah that's the first thing I ever
saw in actually
uh new Stargate movie at the cinema
we're finally at the cinema to see it
screen Fades to Black open shark
Jacqueline
so what am I to begin then recap it yeah
[Laughter]
that would be like
[__] you Amazon
and we're kicking someone's story
[Laughter]
that that would be good that would be
bad I would I would I would genuinely
hate that
and they've done that in other movies
and things so that's the sort of thing
they might they might try and do but
that would be that would be crap oh
sorry and then it gets to the middle of
the movie and you realize it's faked
[Music]
that he died but he faked his own death
he's the Kingpin yeah
you know
um
[Music]
thank you guys this has been an absolute
Joy a really a really good laugh I've
really enjoyed this afternoon it's been
brilliant
um we are back live tomorrow
um I assume it would be the the the
normal boys
um we have got
um it's not normal
about eight minutes in
it but he's not sort of not normal
which is why we've had so much fun
thank you
um these are starting to Sidetrack not
normal
um but yeah so we're live tomorrow I
don't I don't know what we're talking
about tomorrow but I think it's just a
bit of a hangout just and bring so bring
you bring your questions we'll we'll
answer them and we'll talk about stuff
um Star Trek and I'll ask you questions
about that
I want to talk about this 18 Knight
Rider Airwolf fear idea as well so we'll
talk about that a little bit because
there's did you see the short that I
made
ah
I made it sure out of that video I saw
it yesterday I like how I keep going up
and down in the shop
um I wrote a scoped you out it's great
video so if you don't like it it's
Matt's fault and um but there's been a
bit of movement on that so I'll tell you
about that tomorrow
um it's in the story on sidetrack.co.uk
I mention it but I haven't mentioned on
the video yet so
there's been a little bit of movement
it's actually gone a bit further this is
this could actually happen
but I still can't decide whether I love
this idea or hate it I can't decide so
um but we'll have a chat about that
tomorrow
um
and then yeah and then we'll we've got
some big news coming on Tuesday we've
had a little bit of an update from MGM
but we'll drop everything on Tuesday
about that which is interesting and I
think people will be
we have a slightly cryptic response from
MGM
about a question that I've asked
um but we'll drop the video on Tuesday
when we've got a little bit of time to
think about it so we'll drop that
Tuesday and then we'll do a live maybe
Wednesday to talk about it a bit more so
thank you so much Jim been an absolute
pleasure sir thank you
as always just shopping
absolute Legends as always
um um yeah I've really enjoyed this nice
thank you so much everybody thank you
super chats thank you really really
appreciate it
enjoy yourself today guys
cheers
[Music]